we are told ismail made a scaled copy of
the following quadrilateral he used a
scale factor less than one all right
and then they say what could be the
length of the side that corresponds to a
d so a d is right over here a d has
length 16 units in our original in our
original quadrilateral
what could be the length of the side
that corresponds with a d on the scaled
copy of the quadrilateral so it's a
scale factor less than one so we're
going to get something that is less than
16 for that side and the rest of it will
all be scaled by the same factor so the
resulting quadrilateral might look
something
might look something like this this is
just my hand-drawn version so the key
realization is is if our scale factor is
less than 1 this thing right over here
is going to be less than
16 units so let's look at the choices
and it says choose three answers
so pause the video which of these would
match if we're scaling by a factor of
less than one
well we just have to see which of these
are less than 16 units this is less than
16 this is less than 16. this is less
than 16 and those are the only three
that are less than 16. 32 units this
would be a scale factor of two 64 units
this would be a scale factor of four
clearly a scale factor that is not less
than one